law enforcement says memorial day  weekend marks the beginning of the 100  deadliest days of the year on our  roadways they also tell us last year  traffic fatalities were the highest  they've been in 16 years and they  continue to increase police say  impairment is one of the top  contributing factors and they urge  parents to talk with their teenagers  about the issue  it doesn't matter if i'm 16 17 18 95  years old i should not get behind the  wheel when i'm impaired and if you think  you're possibly impaired there's a good  chance that you are well lyft is  offering a discount code this memorial  day weekend that word is smart ride 2  2021 that's the word smart ride 2021  that will get you five dollars off your  ride